dude i a friend of mine goes oh yeah i
try this new pre-workout mix man i need
like you know caffeine and stuff like
that
so i took this pre-workout mix i looked
at the label i think i said to nick
says it's called chaotic or psychotic
pre-workout mix
oh it might be ketamine no i think it's
meth and viagra is in that thing because
i could not stop sweating
christian i know you like to get high in
your adderall just take one little scoop
of this dude and it's so
i couldn't stop sweating i could have
[ __ ] built a
spaceship to mars out of sweat oh dude
that with adderall you'd be
unstoppable or you're gonna die because
my heart was beating like a goddamn
hummingbird
it's my [ __ ] was like we're going to
get work today
we're going overtime we're going to do a
drop set of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i'm going to turn on the ac i can tell
it's still still hitting you guys
my heart's a million miles an hour i see
everything i feel
i feel like one of those you know those
monkeys with the big guys
that's what i feel like i want to attack
you right now
it's so weird do you bring any for the
boys no don't take it
do not [ __ ] take it bro i don't need
anything you don't you
definitely don't need that okay yeah
they'll see you snorting on the side of
the highway in a week
don't do it man i seriously think
there's meth in that thing
yeah it's scary out there gummy candy
it's called that's not baiting for
children
and it also says psychotic across the
middle of it what are you guys trying to
do
it says energy focus pumps psycho
dude i was in there like i'm so excited
i just [ __ ]
i couldn't stop dude i thought y'all are
just trying to go to the gym
dude i'm trying it's a thick boy summer
man i'm trying in shape
by any means necessary but that's where
i draw the line
but didn't you weren't you already doing
fitness like do you need this man's
stuff to how do you know this man
he's my buddy is he and he was just like
hey this is what i use you
you take a bunch of coffee and other
[ __ ] why you can't why not take this
and i looked at the label and said do
not take seven hours before we go into
bed
and also don't take more than one scoop
well i did two scoops
because i thought i'm so caffeinated all
the time this isn't gonna do anything
wrong brendan wrong oh two scoops it was
almost like it's almost like an x-ray i
could see-through people in the gym dude
it was sick really yeah
ooh uh two scoops two scoop shops
at your funeral